[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com it's not often that I go to
FoxNews to illustrate and non-sarcastic
points or go to Fox News to illustrate a
serious political point or news
reporting reality but yesterday we had
this absolutely horrific stock market
crash which was so bad that even Fox
News had to cut away from Donald Trump
bragging about the economy to cover the
precipitous crash of the stock market
and if you're not up to speed on the
fact the last two stock market trading
days and so far early today as well of
MAPE might might have changed by the
time you hear this later today it has
been an absolute disaster last Friday in
the middle of the release of the memo
fiasco which of course ended up being a
total nothing burger as I told you
yesterday uncertainty ramped up the Dow
lost about 666 points now why am i
talking only about the Dow we'll hold on
I'll get to that because I know that's
been a question for many people in the
audience and yesterday once again the
stock market crashing down as much as
1600 points in one day which was about
five percent ultimately ending the day
down 1175 points which was the biggest
single day decline in points in history
but of course we need to adjust for
inflation to find out whether it's the
biggest real decline and of course the
Dow is an average not an index but in
any case the biggest single point
decline during the 2008 financial
meltdown the biggest single-day decline
was 778 points this is a 50% bigger
decline than the biggest previous one
which was during the 2008 economic
crisis now Trump at the time that this
was taking place happened to have gone
to Blue Ash Ohio to brag about how great
the economy was as well
calling Democrats treasonous and a whole
bunch of other stuff and while the
president is bragging about the great
economy the crash starts and even Fox
News had to cut away check this out
Jurgens in thanks to your tax cuts we
see continued success in the future
we're interrupting for breaking news
there is a quite a drop happening on
Wall Street a massive sell-off is
happening today moments ago we were down
more than 900 points on the session
right three and a half percent and it
got WAY worse that was early in the
crash and really just bad optics for
Trump right we have a picture that we're
gonna put up on the screen with the
title Trump tells Sachs sells tax plan
at Ohio factory this is from MSNBC and
then you see on screen at the same time
a bug following the down movement Dow
plunges down 792 points at this time and
here is Donald Trump again calling
Democrats treasonous as the stock market
collapses before our eyes and you have
the other side even on positive news
really positive news like that they were
like death and an American an American
somebody's a treasonous I mean yeah I
guess why not can we call that treason
why not yeah I mean they certainly
didn't seem to love our country very
much so first of all I want to take this
stock market crash in pieces number one
let's debunk the idea that the left is
cheering this I started watching
coverage of this yesterday and you had
all sorts of right-wingers saying it is
horrible that the left is happy that
there was a precipitous market decline
two days in a row I don't know anyone on
the Left that's cheering this I lost as
a result of this what to me is a
significant amount of money I'm not
cheering it I'm not hearing the fact
that the retirement accounts of both
Democrats and Republicans alike are
suffering because of because of this I'm
not cheering it I'm not surprised
because ultimately the empty run-up of
the stock market
was going to fall at some point because
the underlying economic principles of
the Trump White House are not
economically stimulative but no I'm not
cheering and I'm not rooting against the
American economy and I don't know anyone
on the Left Pat that's happy about this
I mean we may not support specific Trump
or Republican policies but the economy
at large of course we want that to
succeed of course it is so much is
riding on this and whether you're a
Democrat or a Republican you want a
strong economy I move a sort of rooting
for the removal of a terrible steward of
the American economy and Donald Trump
that's number one so now let's go
through the layers of this first of all
there's people saying to me rightly so
David hold on you've always said the Dow
isn't a good overall representative of
the stock market and the stock market
isn't the be-all end-all of the economy
well yeah let's take those one by one
the Dow is an average not an index and
of only 30 companies so I think we have
to look past the Dow unfortunately the
Nasdaq which has the biggest tech stocks
in it and the S&P 500 which is a much
broader index of companies also got
crushed on Friday and yesterday the Dow
dropped got the attention as it often
does but the broader markets were also
down significantly and how part two is
is the stock market really a good
indicator of how the economy is doing
and as I've said before it's one part
but it's what Trump has been pointing to
to tout a great economy even though
Trump really hasn't done much that would
justify a such such a huge market run-up
Trump has said because the markets have
increased I'm doing well and conflating
the stock market with the economy was
problematic to begin with but if Trump
believes that the strength of the
economy is in the stock market and if he
believes that the stock markets ran up
because of him then it only follows that
the decline is also both his fault
and indicative of a worsening economy
now I was wondering how is the White
House going to react to this and of
course Trump didn't mention it silence
from the White House except when Sarah
Huckabee Sanders was asked about it she
said listen the day-to-day changes in
the stock market have never really been
a focus of the administration
except for Trump on dozens of occasions
pointing to a new record high in the
stock market other than that you mean
Sarah it's not been a focus of the
administration and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders could be right in the sense that
this could just be a simple correction
and in the next coming days the stock
market in the Dow Jones could go back up
sir
but you never really know the stock
market absent flows and we haven't
really seen a crash this big arguably
since the Great Recession of 2008 2009
2010 and who knows how Trump would
handle a poor economy yeah I don't know
I mean I think he would try to blame
someone else right either Democrats who
aren't working with them or something
left over from Obama or whatever and the
same alt rightists who have been touting
the increased stock market to sort of
cheer Donald Trump's prowess with the
economy are now jumping all board all
aboard the conspiracy train and that's
what I want to talk about next we've
seen the alt-right just pray at the
altar of Trump for the economic success
that they saw through the run-up in the
stock market since Donald Trump was
elected president of the United States
and now that we have seen the biggest
single-day decline in the Dow Jones
Industrial Average on a point basis they
are saying not well maybe we were wrong
about Trump they are saying is this not
a false flag meant to hurt Donald Trump
politically conspiracy theorists and
scams supplement salesmen Alex Jones
tweeted as this was happening is the
historic 1500 point Dow drop a false
flag by the big banks should we
investigate Goldman Sachs it's kind of
funny to mention Goldman Sachs because
Trump's administration is filled with
Goldman Sachs people why why would you
investigate then they're on Trump's team
is the idea that the people on Trump's
team from Goldman Sachs are involved in
crashing the stock market yeah you got
Gary Cohen the chief economic adviser
and Steve my nutrient the Treasury
secretary and your property boys
probably also some lower echelon people
as well that we don't even know right
it's it's unlikely those are the only
two Goldman people that Trump is hired
this is sort of like gas prices right II
the president is responsible for both
the ups and the downs or for neither but
you can't have it both ways and the
horrible part is people fall for this
drivel the real tragedy is that there is
a significant portion of the followers
of Alex Jones and if Donald Trump and
whoever else who fall for this stuff and
there actually is a real conspiracy
theory here it's the one that
unregulated capitalism is sort of a
pyramid scheme that redistributes wealth
from the poor to the rich that's the
real conspiracy here the oleg ARCA code
kleptocratic conspiracy theory they
never talk about that one but this one
they believe and if you look at some of
the responses to Alex Jones tweets
people are eating this stuff up like it
is real one example yes I thought as
much thanks Alex for being one of the
few voices reporting the truth another
person on Twitter who really liked this
from Alex Jones I agree is this the deep
state our our government retaliation
against Trump may sound crazy that
that's right it does but what can we
believe nowadays I won't show you too
many more of these they make me a little
sick to my stomach actually it would be
easier to write this stuff off as a joke
but when you see that it influences so
many people we've got to address it in
some way but the problem that that
exists is the people who believe this
stuff also believe that they will be
told it's not true and that that's part
of the conspiracy so if you go to them
and you say hey hold on a second here's
a reason why this doesn't make sense
here's another reason why this does it
doesn't make sense they will say that's
part of the conspiracy those talking
points are part of the conspiracy so
it's a closed loop it's a there's Doc's
a stick closure to take a phrase from
Peter Bogosian and I don't know how we
should be handling this yeah and
whatever Alex Jones says is gospel to
them - they won't course agree and Alex
Jones has tied himself to Donald Trump
at this point he says that he calls
Trump from time to time oh sure
even
last month he made a phone call to the
White House you believe that I don't
know I mean like you're dealing with the
word of Trump versus Alex Jones right I
tend to that believe it uh Trump in that
scenario is I don't know that's a tough
one you've got Alex Jones and Donald
Trump explaining to you what it is that
you need to do to save humanity I don't
know who you listen to you I really
don't so anyway I know most people in
our audience don't fall for this stuff
but there are people who do and I do
think it's important to point it out
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and we've got one heck of a
program
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Aaron Gossage thank you so much Karen
for joining the David Pakman show and
today's sustaining member of the day is
Brittany John teal who has been a member
dating all the way back to November of
2010 what a day was November 4th 2010
that might have been the day of the
midterms I don't know I've actually had
no idea but it's possible that makes
sense it makes sense that that would be
a day where people would sign up Karen
thank you Brittany thank you join Karen
and Brittany at david pakman.com slash
membership very briefly I previously
told you about the progressive musical
act deep class who is promoting their
self-titled new album also called deep
glass available at CD Baby calm and on
iTunes they did something amazing which
is they sponsored half of 20 David
Pakman show membership and of those 20
yesterday I told you that 7 remained
there are now two of these memberships
left if you want one of these remaining
two half priced yearly memberships they
normally cost $60 deep glass has already
paid for $30 so there's two memberships
left where you pay $30 but you get the
full membership and you get to keep that
price for as long as you want and for
every album sold on cdbaby.com or
through itunes between now and when the
memberships run out three dollars will
be donated to the Institute for Women's
policy research by deep glass so check
out the deep glass self-titled album on
CD Baby and on iTunes and email me if
you want one of the last remaining two
half-price memberships don't assume
someone else will get them because if
everybody does that then we'll have two
memberships unspoken for if you have an
interest in it email me and hopefully
you will get that half-price membership
the shoving into the limelight of Devon
Nunez
by his harebrained involvement in the
FBI's investigation of possible Trump
Russia collusion has been backfiring
hilariously for him first he exposed
himself as a sort of hacky partisan
shill
when while he was running the house
investigation into Trump Russia
collusion he went to the White House to
tell President Trump what was going on
in the investigation absolutely
ludicrous
should have been removed from Congress
for it barely any consequences for him
then he writes this memo summarizing
intelligence he never saw and as I broke
down for you yesterday the memo was
released and even if everything in the
memo is true it exposes nothing major
that would impact the integrity of
Robert Mulder's investigation and we
don't even know if the stuff in the memo
is true but we knew that it contained at
least one major lie about a statement
made or I guess in reality not made by
former FBI director James Comey in 2017
I went through that lie yesterday I
won't do it again today but he
straight-up misrepresents what James
Comey said and now the cherry on top
newness appeared on Fox News's Fox and
Friends and he decided to make the claim
that Donald Trump has never met indicted
Trump crony George papadopolis and sadly
that's what we call a lie in the real
world and there's a picture of Trump and
Papadopoulos together and that picture
has been out for a while let's first
check out Devin Nunez who's becoming
incredibly proficient at digging himself
into holes on Fox and Friends whole
thing goes about Carter page some say
well what about Papadopoulos they
started looking at him earlier what do
you say to that well I would say that if
Papadopoulos was such a major figure why
didn't you get a warrant on him the
Papadopoulos was such a major figure you
had nothing on him you know the guy lied
as far as we can tell Papadopoulos never
even knew who Trump you know never even
had met with the president and and look
getting drunk
in London and talking to other in
talking to diplomats saying that you
don't like Hillary Clinton is really I
think it's kind of scary that our
intelligence agencies would take that
and use it against American citizen
yeah there is no spinning this
whatsoever right here is a picture of
Papadopoulos at a table of maybe ten
people along with Jeff Sessions and
other high-level advisors to trump and
this was a meeting during which
Papadopoulos was meeting with Trump in
his capacity as an advisor now people
have started trying to get ahead of this
saying well Nunez said met with not met
and met with suggests a one-on-one
meeting where they're individually
hanging out but met just means oh well
they might have been in the same place
at the same time at some point as
unlikely as that is we don't really need
to wonder because Trump himself said oh
yeah George papadopolis he's a great guy
remember this audio Walid Phares who you
probably know PhD advisor to the as a
representatives caucus and
counterterrorism expert Carter page PhD
George papadopolis is
energy consultant excellent excellent
so if they didn't know each other it's
an incredible series of coincidences
where Trump is lying or mistaken when he
says he knows Papadopoulos is an
excellent guy and even though they had
an advisory meeting and sat at the same
table they never spoke to each other nor
were introduced but yet Trump still knew
that he was an excellent guy the chain
of facts you have to believe to make
Devon noon as a statement correct is
just too long right Occam's razor
there's a much simpler explanation which
is they know each other they knew each
other and Devon Nunez is lying because
they want to put distance between a guy
who was indicted in the Trump Russia
investigation and Trump yeah I mean you
say that Devin eNOS was lying the other
possibility was that he just didn't know
the meeting between Trump and
Papadopoulos and usually you rank lying
as worth worse than just not knowing
right I mean yes that malice versus
negligence and the law agrees with that
right perjury
you don't you're not going to be a
charged with perjury if you don't
remember something or you don't know but
the thing here is that Devin eNOS is the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee and I'm working on this for a
year yeah so he should know more than I
do and I knew about this meeting that's
exactly the point if Joe down the street
who's busy working and supporting his
family and making vegan sheiks or
whatever he's doing during the day if he
doesn't know the truth about Donald
Trump and George papadopolis as
acquaintances who the hell cares right
is of no consequences when Devin Nunez
who was in a position of real power here
doesn't know something as simple as an
India the investigation did know Trump
and was an advisor to Trump and sat at a
table with Trump then were in real
trouble and Nunez has a habit of lying
about provable statements of facts
misquoting James Comey incorrectly
stating that one of the people indicted
by Robert Moeller's investigation never
met Trump and in fact he's becoming so
blatantly dishonest that not only is it
reminiscent of Trump I'm starting to
wonder whether Trump has something on
Nunez and that's why Nunez is behaving
so erratically but remember when you do
Trump's bidding Trump rewards you and
that's exactly what Trump has been doing
Trump tweeting yesterday about Devin
Nunez representative Devin unas a man of
tremendous courage and grit may someday
be recognized
as a great American hero for what he has
exposed and what he has had to endure
very binary with Trump you live for him
and you're a hero you tell the FBI or
the American people or whoever the truth
and Trump goes after you like a rabid
dog
yeah and contrast that tweet with the
one about Adam Schiff the ranking member
on the House Intelligence right well
he's little Adam Schiff yeah which means
that Trump is starting to recycle his
insults I know it's getting old it's
depressing this is really bad we've got
to watch out of a knot Adam Schiff we've
got to watch it to have a noon s very
very closely
despite the federal government under
Trump and Jeff Sessions moving more and
more and more against marijuana yet
another state is moving forward towards
decriminalization and legalization this
time it's Virginia the Senate in
Virginia voted anonymously 42 zero to
legalize medical marijuana extracts in
the state this is bill SB 726 and it
would allow doctors in Virginia to
recommend cannabidiol oil or THC a oil
for treating a variety of conditions and
diseases House already passed its
version of the bill governor expected to
sign it
CBD and THC a have been shown effective
at dealing with patients suffering from
epilepsy people who need help managing
pain and a number of other conditions
and Virginia is interesting because
they're also being hit very hard by the
opioid crisis and we have studies from
other states that show us not at all
surprisingly that when you legalized or
decriminalized medical and/or
recreational marijuana opioid overdoses
decrease and you know there are people
rightly pointing out David this is so
minor not only is it medical and not
recreational it's just extracts CBD and
THC a it's not even the medical smoking
of the marijuana plant you're right but
the momentum is clear right and my view
on this Pat is when you've got the
federal government going so far so
aggressively in the opposite direction
any step forward even just this from
Virginia is something that we should be
glad about an applaud yeah and to get
that unanimous vote it required 21
Republicans which you have now seen even
ten years ago and I think the GOP is
giving up on this issue it's the next
social
sure that they're gonna lose maybe at
the state level I mean federally
sessions are still pushing hard but
increasingly at the state level you see
it not a priority for Republicans and
you know we need to go as full
legalization and most importantly the
rescheduling of marijuana at the federal
level we've got to get it out of
schedule one right scheduled one is
supposed to be reserved for the most
dangerous and addicting substances with
no medical benefits cannabis clearly
does not fit into that category yet it
remains a Schedule one at the federal
level small victory but the small
victories are adding up and that's a
very very good good thing and I know
it's just extracts of medical uses a non
psychoactive non psychoactive but it's
better than nothing and eventually they
will come around we have a discussion
forum on Reddit at david pakman.com /r
edit check it out discuss politics with
other David Pakman show viewers and
listeners we'll take a quick break and
be back with a welcome the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm joined today by dr. Steven beYOU sir
who is a clinical psychiatrist also a
former major in the United States Air
Force he's an editor along with Leonard
cruise who's been a guest on the program
of a clear and present danger narcissism
in the era of President Trump so let's
start if we can with the recent
assessment that was done of Donald Trump
the Montreal cognitive assessment done
as part of what was really a physical
exam by the White House dr. Ronnie
Jackson from a medical perspective how
valuable is that 30 point assessment in
figuring out whether a patient might be
experiencing some of the early signs of
cognitive decline for cognitive decline
it's a good test but only in the more
severe cases you know a lot of people
have been looking since that you know
report at the Montreal cognitive
assessment and when you look at it it's
a very basic exam you need to name to be
animals or an asura sac animal and a
lion need to do very simple arithmetic
you know you need to draw the face of a
clock so it's really not you know
high-level evaluation now it is good if
somebody had severe dementia if somebody
had clinically severe Alzheimer's
disease those things can be difficult to
do but it's really not a good test of
the cognitive abilities you need to be
presidency yeah I mean when I saw that
you get six out of 30 points you get 20%
for just telling the interviewer the
date and city where the exam is being
conducted that strikes me as testing for
something far more advanced than what is
even being sort of hypothesized about
Donald Trump right right it's not bad as
a kindergarten enters exam if you want
to see if your shower was rape in the
garden it would be good for that or if
you had a severe question of Alzheimer's
disease but again the complexities of
running the government you know that is
by far you know not a suitable test the
other concern is
himself supposedly asked for the exam
and that's highly unusual as a clinician
you know we're always suspect if a
patient asks for a specific test because
there's no way to know that that patient
didn't prep area for that test can you
talk to us a little bit more about what
would be a more accurate way of testing
for what it is that is sort of
concerning about Trump's behavior right
there been a number of concerns around
your president Trump really since the
beginning of the election process back
in 2016 you know one concern was
narcissism we put out a book you know
clear and present danger nurses in the
era of President Trump where we looked
at narcissistic elements within it and
there's been a lot written a lot spoken
of you know since then there's further
concerns of emotional stability I wrote
a piece of New York Times about would he
be safe you know with the nuclear
reliability yeah criterion and then
there's the third piece which you've
alluded to today which is cognitive
abilities when you look at a 71 year old
gentleman the oldest person to enter his
first term in the presidency who has
unusual judgments who has declining
vocabulary with reliance on superlatives
that yeah has difficulty completing of
thoughts there are increasing concerns
that somebody like that may indeed have
a cognitive impairment the only good way
to assess that would be a full
neuropsychological evaluation which is
you know three to eight hours in
duration it's not a ten minute you know
quickening a manual task but as an
in-depth you know psychological tests
and by a neuropsychologist it could
really root out early you know cognitive
impairments nobody is saying that he's
got severe dementia at this point but
what many are concerned of does he have
early account impairment you know for
somebody who's in their seventies we now
know that at some point during his
presidency Ronald Reagan was already
experiencing some cognitive decline as a
result of Alzheimer's is your sense that
even Reagan at that time would have
passed the Montreal cognitive assessment
most likely of course it's impossible to
answer that because as far as I know he
didn't have the test but correct at the
the point where Ronald Reagan was in
office and there were people with
concerns it would have been quite easy
to pass the Montreal cognitive
assessment I suspect that's a guess of
course but that is not a native thought
at mass so I know that there will be
people who watch this interview listen
to this interview doctor and they will
say wait hold on a second what happened
to this principle of never evaluating or
even approximating possible diagnosis
for someone that a psychiatrist has not
examined directly and in person isn't
that what dr. beYOU sir is doing he's
using media clips and appearances of
Donald Trump to hypothesize about what
may be going on cognitively and that is
something that the medical community
community looks down upon can you talk a
little bit about that and how those sort
of stand there have shifted over time
with regard to certain types of
conditions you're quite right there's
only a debate particularly the American
Psychiatric Association and whether it's
reasonable to diagnose a public figure
from a park and that's known as the
Barry Goldwater rule going back to the
1964 election between LBJ and Barry
Goldwater and it's been widely accepted
mostly that psychiatrists and
psychologists shouldn't formally
diagnosed a politician or anybody in the
public eye based solely on observed
criterion and in our book we actually
talk a lot about that we have an entire
chapter on the Goldwater rule and we
actually agree mostly with the Goldwater
rule and I've been very careful both of
my writing and my public appearance is
to not diagnose and down prone with
anything now that doesn't mean we can't
be concerned with what we see that
doesn't mean we can't raise alarms and
doesn't mean we can't urge further
evaluation so while I can't and won't
formally diagnosing president Trump with
a narcissistic sound disorder with
emotional instability you know with a
cognitive to
impairment I can certainly say I've seen
yeah evidence you know symptoms that
that any reasonable person would want
you in further evaluation remember this
is the the man who as president you know
should he wake up tomorrow morning and
decide he wants to launch a nuclear
attack those nuclear missiles that in
the air and five minutes and those
missiles cannot be recalled the cannon
be deported they will strike their
target that could lead to a full-scale
nuclear exchange which really could and
civilization as we know it on the planet
so do you want somebody that we're
concerned about that destroy the planet
in five minutes time that you feel
comfortable ignoring an evaluation not
getting further information why do we
not at least want that evaluation to be
option to protect the safety of the
American people yeah I mean I would say
on the basis of identifying a giraffe
and a tiger I would say I don't want him
having the button if he could have
identified like a capybara in that exam
you might be able to convince me
otherwise
let's let's talk about the nuclear
weapon aspect of it what specifically
about all the different behaviors makes
you most concerned when it comes to that
example that you've mentioned twice now
the nuclear launch capability that Trump
has as president exactly the nuclear
concern has been one of my stronger
concerns more recently well he spoke a
lot about narcissism early on in the
campaign my bigger concern currently is
is about nuclear or yes accessibility I
served 12 years in the Air Force and as
a psychiatrist one of my roles was to
evaluate military personnel to see if
they were fit for duty and if they were
working with nuclear and materiel the
criterion for fitness for duty was that
much stronger Department of Defense to
regulation 52 ten-point 42 lays it out
it says only those personnel with the
highest degree of reliability
trustworthiness conduct and behavior
she'll be allowed to work in the
vicinity of nuclear weapons they got me
thinking suppose President Trump were
instead Airmen
and supposed airman Trump was stationed
at the base I would zap and suppose had
a clear outside evidence that airman
Trump was engaged in sexually abusive
behavior towards women that he was
cyberbullying on Twitter that was prone
to erratic emotional states that he was
paranoid at times about being surveilled
or persecuted unjustly and that he had
times of making highly distorted if not
frankly untruthful comments would I be
willing to certify airman Trump has
nuclear ready under their criterion my
answer was immediately no absolutely not
not without further a psychological
evaluation something like that we would
have done much more testing to see would
they be safer on nuclear weapons so
that's the great irony then that the
entire nuclear chain of command from the
amp and in the missile silo to the
Chairman the Joint Chiefs of Staff are
all held to this very high degree of
psychological stability and readiness
except one person and that's the United
States the very person who has his
finger on the nuclear button there was
actually other examples of that as well
I mean we talked about with these Access
Hollywood you know grab them by the you
know what tapes how the other person on
those tapes the host of the program
Billy Bush he lost his job and Trump
went on to become president of the
United States the the the theme of the
different standard seems to be a more
and more common one doesn't it it does
it really does and that gets to what can
we do about this
you know if the stakes are really that
high if the world could be plunged into
clear war in five minutes with
catastrophic consequences you know why
do we have the whole chain of command
under you know tight scrutiny except you
know the one person the person United
States there are actually a number of
initiatives in Congress as we speak to
to help this to add to the safety and
security of American people one is House
bill 669 with the Senate bill 200
version sponsored by representative Liu
Liu and Senator Markey that's the
restriction for the first use of nuclear
weapons Act of 2017 which basically
states that no president will have the
authority to launch a first strike
nuclear attack without the consent of
Congress now
there's a metalli ation needed if
somebody attacks us we can instantly
attack that but were there to be put
into law you know president would be
allowed to initiate that attack and we
think of it why do we need to destroy
the planet in five minutes when we could
just as easily destroy the planet in
three to four days to liberation or
perhaps get a different solution over
those days I'd like to talk a little bit
about narcissistic personality disorder
my dad who's also a psychiatrist but was
trained in Argentina sort of half
jokingly once said to me narcissistic
personality disorder is what we
developed to be able to assign a
diagnosis to people who are just
flat-out insufferable and of course he
was half kidding when he said that but
the right question is when it comes to
the fitness to serve as president
narcissistic personality disorder is not
in the same league as some form of
cognitive decline or dementia right
we're talking about two different things
indeed depending how we define it
there's narcissistic traits there's
narcissistic personality style and this
narcissistic personality disorder you
know those are in a spectrum of severity
and it's really hard to to determine you
know which of those may be going on
again about you know further evaluation
cognitive deterioration though is so
much more clear and dangerous and
verifiable on testing not that
narcissism isn't but if somebody has
early cognitive impairments that will
likely progress and is highly dangerous
yeah in this kind of condition so yeah I
think we're talking about a whole
different concern at that level last
thing I want to touch on did you see
that very bizarre video of Trump like he
had a huge wad of chewing gum in his
mouth when he was giving a speech and
then signing an executive order that's
been the subject of lots of speculation
in terms of loose dentures or whatever
else are you familiar with that video
there are so many videos it's actually
hard to say because I've seen President
Trump in numerous cases yes I do believe
I know the one year referring to you
with that yes so we were ultimately told
that that was the result of dry mouth
due to a medication
that the president was taking there was
speculation about loose dentures but
really rich people tend to have dental
implants not dentures and in any case we
were told after the medical exam Trump
doesn't have dentures does that entire
incident feel okay to you now in terms
of we've gotten a satisfactory
explanation or is it still a suspect
incident in your mind well it's
certainly not okay particularly the
broader context if that was really the
only event that we were concerned about
then you maybe could be explained away
with that but if you spend five minutes
on Google and just type in an unusual
behavior by President Trump on YouTube
you will find enormous amounts of
material out there all on video all
captured you know this is a man who
really struggles to complete a sentence
his sentences are long they're run on
repetitive he uses these superlatively
in fashion you really get the sense that
something just isn't right in a mocha
the Montreal cognitive assessment is not
reassuring that does not give us
significant information we the only
thing that would reassure me would be a
non-partisan would have to be somebody
who you know it didn't have a political
slant and maybe multiple evaluators but
a nonpartisan neuropsychological
in-depth many hours evaluation that's
the only thing that would satisfy me at
this point to really be reassured that
the American people are in safe hands
with this president we've been speaking
to dr. Steven Boozer he's a clinical
psychiatrist former major in the United
States Air Force and he also edited with
Leonard Cruise the book a clear and
present danger narcissism in the era of
the president Trump thanks so much for
sharing your insights
thank you so much David really
appreciate it the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
we had some actual good news yesterday
of it's bad for Republicans and bad for
people who are looking to suppress the
vote but it's actually good news for
democracy we had pennsylvania supreme
court previously ruled back in january
that the way that the districts are
currently drawn in pennsylvania benefits
republicans in other words it's been
gerrymandered to all hell and back for
the benefit of the republican party and
this is not a shock right there's been a
number of different major efforts in
pennsylvania for years to combine
gerrymandering with voter ID to help
republicans win elections and just as a
reminder remember when mike Terzi the
Speaker of the Pennsylvania House of
Representatives back in the MIT Romney
candidacy days he straight up talked
about this and and did not even make an
attempt to hide it as anything other
than the political attack that it is
remember this audio voter ID which is
gonna allow Governor Romney to win the
state of Pennsylvania done
[Music]
so anyway that that clip is always just
disturbing as soon as the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court ruled last month that they
need to redraw the districts in
Pennsylvania because it's just again
gerrymandered to hell by Republicans
there was an immediate appeal the
Supreme Court of the United States the
the big Supreme Court not the state
Supreme Court the real one held an
emergency hearing and they decided yeah
the decision from the lower court stands
Pennsylvania is going to have to redraw
those districts and very soon in
accordance with the lower court's order
and when I looked at the numbers the
Pennsylvania gerrymandering is so bad
that even though there are 800,000 more
registered Democrats than Republicans in
Pennsylvania Republicans have held 13 of
the 18 decisions during the three
election cycles since the gerrymandering
took place in 2011 not even just a
simple majority I mean has a landslide
different it is a landslide difference
and I know that you know when Trump
gives a speech and the Dow drops 1500
points this story seems almost too small
to even make a difference but Windsor
wins and this is a win and we should be
happy about it well I guess it's a
little bit of a win but Republicans got
to use their gerrymandered map for
reelection seven out of the ten years
that that would be in place right that's
why the census is so important we have
the census we have redistricting and
even if you immediately identify an
injustice in that districting it can
take seven years to get it fixed and
it's important to clarify the
Pennsylvania Court decided that the
gerrymandering violated the Pennsylvania
Constitution and the Supreme Court
agreed there are people who are
misinterpreting or maybe misreporting
this they are confused there are people
who believe because the Supreme Court
agreed with the lower court ruling what
they've said is that the gerrymandering
was unconstitutional federally that
would be so huge because if the Supreme
Court ruled that what Pennsylvania did
violates the Federal Constitution that
becomes precedent in other states but
unfortunately that's not what the
Preem Court ruled the Supreme Court
ruled merely that the Pennsylvania Court
was correct that their state
constitution had been violated period
this says nothing about the
constitutionality of the gerrymandering
ploys that are happening at the federal
constitutional level still the right
decision so I take it that the
Pennsylvania GOP will be back at it in
2021 of course and this is what
Republicans do if you can't win the
hearts and minds of voters over you
start emphasizing voter ID laws and
gerrymandering get any way that you can
get an advantage and this is why I've
been saying census census 2020 sounds
boring very very important one of our
viewers has completely cocked Alex Jones
this is the best we have bumper stickers
here at the David Pakman show
and I recently got an email from Ryan
who's been a member for a couple of
years already and he wrote to me and he
said David every day driving to work I
have to stop right next to a transformer
like an electrical transformer
that has been branded with an info wars
bumper sticker since you clearly
understand the insanity of Alex Jones
and Infowars I wondered if you would
send me a david pakman show
bumper-sticker
on the promise that it would be used to
cover up the atrocity that is this
Infowars sticker i've been a member in
daily listener for around two years now
and i would much rather see your sticker
when I Drive to work Ryan asked and I
delivered so he sent his pictures this
was my condition you got to send his
pictures of this thing Ryan sent to me
and we're putting up on the screen this
is the electrical transformer before
Ryan got to it this is the view from the
road and then he also took a close-up of
the infowars.com
sticker on this electrical transformer
and I present to you now that same
sticker covered up by a david pakman
show bumper-sticker and you can see just
the little last edge of the Infowars
bumper sticker and it has been
completely almost completely covered
yeah by the permanent marker would do
the rest
you could fill in that little white part
with permanent marker if you really were
committed to it and you can see it
from across the street this is the best
he went back across the street and took
a picture of it and it's very clearly
the david pakman show logo the david
pakman show bumper-sticker and here is
ryan celebrating the accomplishment with
the bumper sticker in the background
this is a fantastic job by Ryan Wright I
mean this is huge I love it because the
people that live in that house are
probably so confused as to what's good
they knew what Infowars was but if they
see that david pakman show they're going
to investigate I wonder if the people in
the house are the people who put the
Infowars bumper sticker on the thing in
the first place yeah haven't there been
stories about matches made in heaven
where someone's like a viewer was
driving behind another viewer who has a
david pakman show bumper-sticker there's
been a couple sightings each other
yep so someone in Newton Massachusetts
was once driving and they're fans of the
show and they saw another car driving
around with the david pakman show
bumper-sticker and then I believe in
Tennessee there was another one where I
remember viewers getting in touch one
viewer said hey I saw and I remember
what kind of car it was say it was you
know a Prius not to stereotype but maybe
it was a Prius or whatever I saw a Prius
with the david pakman show
bumper-sticker in this town and I
announced it and shortly thereafter
someone wrote in and they said oh yeah I
a drive a Prius around in that town all
the time it's the same color car and I
have a david pakman show bumper-sticker
yeah I'm like I'd love it if in a few
months from now someone writes in saying
that I was driving down a road in
Rochester New York and I saw david
pakman show bumper-sticker on a
transformer did I I might have forgotten
to even say that this was Rochester New
York we allowed to say that no we are
yeah I just don't I don't know if I did
anyway Ryan you did it you cooked them
and what what else can I say
congratulations and with peace and love
let's do it again sometime somewhere
else get in touch if there are prominent
stickers you want to cover up in other
parts of the country we have a voicemail
number that number is two one nine two
david p and i got a voicemail that is at
least partially dealing with the massive
stock market crash that we saw earlier
this week let's take a listen to it
together
hi David Patrick my name is Ralph and
I'm from a gerrymandered portion of
Pennsylvania right that's not why I
called the stock market has been
dropping and it
can't be the fault of Donald Trump's so
how did those despicable Democrats
sabotage him I on YouTube I yep I
actually tweeted sarcastically yesterday
something along the lines of the stock
market decline can't have anything to do
with Trump's policies because his tax
cut has given people even as much as a
dollar and fifty cent quick income tax
reduction this is clearly Obama's fault
Obama and Hillary in orange jumpsuits
soon or something like that and most
people who follow me understood that it
was total sarcasm but there were
actually some people who said David
you're delusional that's Hillary and
Obama are never gonna be in orange
jumpsuits
so even I guess I was so serious in my
tweet that I even tricked some of my own
followers of sarcasm sarcasm doesn't
always work on social media yeah I
noticed like I remember you had a tweet
just recently about how you believe the
Trump was 6-3 in 239 pounds you also
believe the validity of the Nunez memo
sure yeah and it doesn't always
translate well but that's kind of the
fun I'm sorry yeah I'm on social media
all right
you can find me on Twitter at D Pakman
and you're on Twitter also right are you
producing a hat for dues reporters your
pet forward on Twitter you know it's
it's all happening and the Eggman tweets
you sometimes doesn't he yeah or direct
messages organizing worse that's another
thing Gary the authorities have been
notified
now we're kidding Eggman that's we're
actually they had to in they have been
notified but not because of the Eggman's
messages on the bonus show today the
White House plans to give restaurant
owners more control over tips that's not
a plan that a lot of people are thrilled
with particularly people who work in
restaurants Michele Bachmann has decided
that she's not going to try to win Al
Franken's former Senate seat because she
didn't hear from God that she should do
it
and there is a woman who says she won a
six hundred million dollar jackpot in
the lottery but she has as yet left the
prize unclaimed and we will talk about
why and we will talk about whether Pat
or I would do something similar if we
were to win the lottery Anna will talk
about the lottery a little more broadly
maybe I'm interested in lotteries I
think it's a it's a whole the whole
thing I know you could get access to the
bonus show in two ways number one become
a member at david pakman.com slash
membership very very easy way to do it
number two become a patron at at least
the $5 a month level at patreon.com
slash david pakman show both means get
you access to the same world-famous
bonus show and I look forward to speak
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you